[Music]
if you've ever thought that you had a
good memory you can put yourself to the
test here because we're going to show
you a range of memory puzzles stay until
the end when we'll see if you can work
out what happens when something is taken
away if this is your first time visiting
the things then what would be really
good it would be if you could give this
video a thumbs up and hit the subscribe
button today we are going to show you 9
out of 10 people fail this photographic
memory test which logos are rights
sometimes we see things every day speaks
tint that we might actually not know
when it's wrong for instance we all see
company logos a lot then how well do you
really remember them this next question
is based on famous brand logos and their
colors first of all we are going to show
you the Pepsi logo pretty familiar right
but which order do the colors go are
they red white and blue or blue white
and red are you ready to give us your
answer it's red white and blue now which
of these Google logos is right no
sneaking off to search for it that's it
it's the one where both the first oh and
the key are red now let's get
interplanetary four minutes we're going
to show you the NASA logo that is the
blaze on the NASA logo pink or is it red
what do you think the answer is we'll
tell you now it's red next up we'd like
you to deliver the right answer for
which UPS logo is correct think you know
well it's the one with the darker
lettering and finally we'd like to know
which one of these pieces is the one
you'd find on your car who will tell you
it's the one with the blue writing how
many of them did you get right it's
harder than it seems
can you remember so let's do our first
memory test we are going to show you a
picture then you are going to move on
and then we will ask you something about
it
are you ready here's the picture pay
attention to it study it take in the
details and try to remember everything
you possibly can about it memory is
controlled by a part of our brains
called the hippocampus we reckon that's
a bit of an
name it usually comes from the Greek
word meaning sea horse because when the
brain is dissected it sort of looks like
a seahorse that's pretty gross right
anyway the hippocampus is the part of
the brain which is responsible for
storing processing and creating our
memories with diseases that affect
memory the hippocampus is one of the
first parts of the brain to be targeted
but while we were telling you all that
interesting and important information we
hope that you were able to keep thinking
about that picture we showed you now
what we want to ask you is how many cats
were in the picture you can pause our
video here if you like if that helps you
remember the answer to that question is
7 did you get it right if you did then
well done and if you didn't you
shouldn't worry too much because that
was a pretty hard question who's who
we're going to go back to give you a
memory test based on a picture you'll
have to pay attention to it because we
are going to ask you a question about it
here is the picture make sure you take a
really good look because this is all
part of the task that we're doing in
this video we hope you're enjoying it by
the way did you know that perhaps the
best memory in the world right now
belongs to a man called Michelle
Narayana
Michelle is from Hyderabad India and he
is one of the youngest Chartered
Accountants in that country he qualified
when he was 19 two years before he could
really practice accountancy but the
reason we were talking about him today
is that when he was just 13 years old he
held two spots in the Guinness Book of
Records he was able to memorize 132
digits in one minutes setting the record
for the longest number sequence
memorized in one minute that meant he
was a double world record holder because
when he was 11 he held the record for
the most random objects memorized having
remembered 225 random objects in 12
minutes it's question time which of
these figures in the picture was the
only one
was there headed what color was it and
where was it in relations to the others
misuse of the yellow one in the middle
you'd be right the right words memory
quizzes are a lot of fun well we think
that anyway and we hope that you do too
but they can also be useful here's a
test that book publishers scholastic
used to see if there's a problem with
someone's short-term memory possibly
caused by using substances there are 15
words and you have to study them for a
short period of time and then repeat
them back or write them down those words
are eggs drawing rock Apple focus
mission favored
rein flag trial partner house life chair
and ice seems pretty simple does it's
but if you go off and give yourself a
bit of time before you see if you can do
it and it just might get a little bit
harder for you so can you remember the
words pause this video and give yourself
some time to write them all down don't
take too long but see if you can wrap
your brain for the answers here they are
eggs drawing rock Apple focus mission
favored brain flag trial partner house
lights chair and ice how did you do
don't worry if you didn't get them
alright interestingly the normal number
of words people get is usually somewhere
between seven and nine so if you manage
to get more than that you have a really
good short-term memory emojis one of the
many things that have become incredibly
popular and iconic in the last few years
has been the emoji with the rise of
smartphones we have seen an increase in
the number of emojis that we can use
so what BuzzFeed journalist Ben Henry
did as a memory test is brilliant we
love it and we want to try it out on you
here's the picture of the emojis that
been used in his tests take a good look
at them and study them you can pause the
video here if you want are you ready to
take our version of the test we'd like
to know what the emoji on the far left
of the second row is now we would like
to know the one diagonally to the bottom
right of that after that we wonder if
you could remember what emoji was in the
top right hand corner of the picture and
also the one inmediately to the left of
that have you got those there's two more
and that's
in the middle of the bottom row and the
one immediately above and to the right
the answers are the hardflip
gift-wrapped Santa Claus headphone with
music lemon crazy ghost and the burger
how did you do it's a harder test than
you might think and we have to give Ben
Henry credit math whiz it's one thing to
have a good memory but it's better if
you can use it for a purpose that's why
we love this very tricky math quiz which
was created by Danielle finger and put
on the play buzz website it was so
fiendishly tricky it became popular it
was covered by news outlets across the
world it goes like this
take the number 4 and multiply it by 2
now add 7 to that then you have to go
and add 5 to that then divide that
number by 2 are you keeping track of
this we hope so because if we aren't
anywhere near the end yet you now have
to subtract 3 from that number then
multiply that by 6 and then you have to
multiply that number by 3 are you
keeping up we hope you are now you have
to add 17 to that number and add 59 to
the number you got then it's time to
divide that by 2 subtract 15 multiply
that 5 2 and then subtract your very
first number will give you a moment what
did you get the correct answer should
have been 168 that was pretty tricky
wasn't it you were so busy doing the
sums you might have forgotten the first
number no wonder Danielle's quiz was a
big hit we really had to make sure that
we got it right and that we remembered
everything number sequence if you've got
a good memory and a talent for recalling
things then you might want to enter a
memory competition these things are very
popular and they attract a good standard
of entries this next memory test is
based on something designed to be
similar to the questions that
participants of the UK's jr. memory
championships are asked so here we go
we'll show you some numbers then you
have to remember that here we go 1 4 9
71 18
2:23 1254 3178 9250 514 1621 33 67 75 8
right and now we've told you them here
are three questions which number came
immediately after 18 what's the tenth
number in the sequence we just showed
you and which number comes immediately
before 16 you should pause the video
here if you want to have a bit of time
to try to remember okay are you ready
for the answers they are 72 31 and 14
how did you do if you didn't do very
well then don't worry about it too much
what you have to remember is that this
particular quiz is based on something
that is a national competition so it's
going to be pretty tricky but imagine
doing something like this in a
competitive environment so we don't know
about you but we would find it very hard
join the dots okay this next memory test
is incredibly difficult it's a
combination of logic observation and
memories take a look at these pictures
there are some red and blue dots take a
look at them for a little while because
we are going to ask you to remember them
a little bit later right we think that
that's enough we'll take the pictures
away for a bit but keep what you've seen
of them in your head while we are on the
subject of memory here is an interesting
fact about it did you know that there's
a link between intelligence and memory
although for years people have been
using IQ tests as a way to calculate
intelligence there has been research
carried out that shows that your working
memory which is how well you can store
information and then use it to do
something is actually a far better
indicator of intelligent than doing an
IQ test which amazed us but then we
thought about it and it made sense we
hope that you have remembered those
pictures from earlier by the way
combined the red dots in each picture
and what do you get
pause the video if you need to the
answer to that is the letter D did you
get that one right well if you didn't
the good news is that you can train your
memory so that's a way of getting more
intelligence Kim's game take a look at
this picture which was created by the
people at the UK's National Mountain
Sports Center in Plaza Brennan wells
what we are going to do is to play a
game that you just might have heard of
its called Kim's game the aim of the
game is to try to remember as many
things from this picture as possible
it's a game that is incredibly popular
with scouting groups all over the world
are you ready to remember you can write
your answers down if you like but you
will want to take some time to remember
the objects so feel free to hit the
pause button now Kim's game takes its
name from Anglo Indian writer Rudyard
Kipling's novel Kim by the way if you
recognize Rudyard Kipling's name he is
the man who wrote The Jungle Book
anyway Kipling's popularity in early
twentieth century Britain meant his work
was incredibly influential and that is
how the idea of this game got so popular
that we are sure that you are ready to
check your answers here's the picture we
showed you earlier how many of them did
you guess we wonder whether you were
able to get everything most things or
whether you didn't get anything right at
all it's harder than it seems what goes
where today we are talking about
memories and about how we can test our
memories by playing some games and
taking some tests this next game is no
different and we like it very much so
here we go take a look at this picture
and if you feel it would help you with
all make sure to click on the pause
button to give you a bit more time now
we hope that you have been able to
remember this picture we wondered what
part of the photo grows in what bits how
about the man's hands how about his face
and what about this piece of the
background it's harder than you thought
it was going to be right well here are
the answers
the hands are towards the left of the
picture about halfway down his face is
also in the middle although in this case
it's a little bit right of center and
that bit of the background is in the top
left-hand corner of the picture we hope
you did okay but with all these quizzes
we have been thinking a lot about these
things how well did you do which bits
did you find the trickiest and do you
know of any other cool memory tests and
quizzes for us to try out don't be shy
let us know by telling us in the
comments section and that's all for 9
out of 10 people fail this photographic
memory test if you liked it then we
think your next port of call should be
10 mystery riddles only the smartest 5%
consol thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]